good evening everybody welcome offices
and visitors bound and counselors thank
you
before we start do we have the emergency
evacuation Elsbeth shouldn't we be
required to evacuate the building would
you please leave the building further
nearest available exit there are two
fire exits in this room if you need to
evacuate the room by the door to the
fire escape
staircase please hold both pan rails in
case the stairs are wet or slippery if
anyone is unable to use the stairs would
they please allow others to exit the
room before they go to the fire escape
door where they can be then given
assistance please do not use the lift
our assembly point will be in the public
car parked at the side of the Civic
suite please do not delay our evacuation
to collect any belongings please do not
return to the podium until given
permission to do so by Council staff
please note that this meeting will be
audio recording thank you first of all
if we could have apologies please thank
you there are these substitute members
thank you
non-members attending minutes of the
meeting held on the 20th of June is
anybody happy for me to sign those great
to receive declarations of interest
external auditors report updates to
consider the report of the assistant
director democratic services which
provides an update on progress in the
respective external auditor
recommendations Thank You Jenna thank
you This report provides an update on
all your recommendations made by if
Stonewall's as part of their 2015-16
will be work matters arising from their
annual report can be fully implemented
and there is one recommendation from the
2015-16 grants report on page six point
nine which remains outstanding
[Music]
everybody's happy with me - thank you
thank you seven financial statements and
service bar have ever since our
colleague from Ernst and Young to
external auditors he'll present his
audit of all initially and then I will
follow up presenting the financial
statements in best way I can
and then we'll invite if we can invite
questions after Kevin has completed his
pace on the three wire and then
obviously we will ask the questions
after us for the Rajputs I don't know if
I could direct members down to the staff
of our report which is on pace and we're
going for
so the purpose of the report is to
update you on the results of the
completion of our orbits it takes you
through the key issues of you
highlighted in our activity in March is
here and summarizes the key findings
from the audience the headline and to
put this in perspective is that we
intend to give an unqualified opinion on
the statement of accounts and and all
applied value-for-money conclusion so
what they do run through the key
findings it's behind that and then now I
tackle any questions if I could direct a
committee to page seven point 103 this
section area report sets out the key
risks that we identified that the start
of the audit and our findings around
them so firstly the risk of fraud in
revenue recognition and essentially to
make sure that the right money's in the
right pops
especially around an assuring capital
and revenue expenditure are treated
appropriately the level of capital
expenditure for the year the council was
quite low and that we were happy that
the amount recorded as capital did meet
definitions the next risk was around
management override so this is
essentially recognizing that whatever
the control environment is put in place
management they're always in the
position where they can go around those
controls so we look at in areas such as
journals in estimates to see if there
are being aimed at any particular
results or any unusual or what
transactions have put Frehley accounts
I'm happy to report which we have not
found any undue findings in any of those
areas
on page 7.55 we set out a risk regarding
the new presentation of the account this
year
sips I have changed the format to better
reflects or better in their view was
let's what they believe the financial
sport and should make a flavor to bring
your own budgeting and internal
management reporting through the
statutory accounts so what we've have to
do and this is how management have
represented last year's accounts in that
new formats as well as a look at this
year's accounts and apart from just one
liner airing in terms of the casting of
the statements as presenters we were
cathy without restatements and no
further necessary to your attention the
next two pages concern and the two
largest elements on your balance sheets
which are made up of significant
estimates so these are the valuation of
property plant and equipment and then
secondly the pension liability in point
for these areas we are raising some
concerns about the estimation techniques
but ultimately in both cases we have set
out a range in terms of our procedures
and the valuations both do fall within
those ranges in terms of the property
plant and equipment the concern that we
have with the council's value is is that
we believe their approach is overly
formulaic and we don't believe it takes
into account the individual evidence of
the assets that are being valued when
they rely too heavily on a formula
driven approach to produce the figures
and we have had discussions with valuers
we have reached agreements and better
understanding in terms of their
processes but we do we do think that in
terms of how they assess the
obsolescence of assets and how they
calculate their fees if their valuations
do tend to be on the high side and so
we're just reporting that and for your
attention
it's always the possibility that in
future use that made
become material issues in terms of the
pension valuations it's much of the same
sort of thing we set out our assumptions
in terms of the appropriate ranges using
pension actuary actuarial experts
employed by the National Audit Office
and ourselves internally in terms of the
actuaries employed by the ESA pension
funds particularly for discount rates
and inflation rates we believe their
assumptions are a little bit on the high
side so if I'm a little striped on a
scale of one to ten we believe that
probably around nine or anything like
that so again we're happy because it
does fall within that range of one to
ten but we are raising that because
again in future years it could be that's
not the right result and we could have
will need to be having some discussions
about the assumptions they're being made
if I could then move the members on to
page seven point one one for this page
illustrates the key findings from the
audits in terms and the adjustments that
have been made there are two adjustments
that have impacted general funds of the
council
first of all management identified to us
that they had emitted a benefits journal
for the year and secondly there was a
error in treatment of the pants within
the financial system taken together
those two have reduced the available
general fund reserve from 1.7 million to
1.3 million the next significant item
reflects changes on the balance sheets
where the fixed asset register hadn't
been properly updated to take account of
land values as well as building values
and we'd identified this occurred both
in the current year and also affected
last year so prior year restatements had
to be undertaken to make sure that both
views reflect the proper values of the
SS this one doesn't affect the reserves
of council because it impacts upon
property plant equipment the impact is
quite
place it to be accounts did involve
quite a significant additional piece of
work strap those amendments free to all
the appropriate places there were also a
few disclosure misstatements and
emissions which we've highlighted for
your attention but none of those in the
general reserves and there are no
uncorrected misstatements so the
accounts has presented on the paper this
evening do include all the corrections
and issues of we've identified during
the course of the Audion ii our
responsibility is to ensure that the
council has adequate arrangements in
place to feed value for money for its
residence from page 7 point 1 1 6 we set
out the two key risks that we identified
in our audit plan and are finding this
time again so the firstly the risk was
around financial resilience the council
recognizes a gap over its medium term
financial plan approximately two point 1
million pounds so we've looked at the
arrangements that were in place up to
the 31st of March 2017 to ensure that
there are appropriate arrangements be
put in place to address that over the
period event after that plan and pretty
clean we are happy those arrangements
are in place we don't expect that to be
immediately resolved because the council
has to set an annual budget doesn't have
to close that gap at this present point
in time but we're happier the key
assumptions it's making within plans and
within its budget and the fact that
you're identifying savings plans going
forward that you have the processes in
place to address that gap over time
based upon the information that we know
the second of our risks of rounds and
governments and processes for setting up
your and led the 40 trading company
green gateway and so we've looked at the
processes management we've gone about
and setting up that company looking at
the advices sorts for example and make
sure that advice has been appropriately
acted upon again we are happy with those
arrangements that have been put in place
and so overall we're proposing to give
the unqualified value for money
conclusion that previously mentioned the
only other thing that I need to bring to
the committee's attention so you need to
get questions asked upon this so I think
it's best to bring it out because of the
area's we've identified in terms of the
accounts this year and the addition of
work we've had to undertake for example
on the areas in fixed assets and the
prior year which they will be charging
you additional fee for the audience and
having now drops the end we will put a
number on that and discuss it with Rob
for agreements and then we'll bring that
final figure back to you and probably
your next committee in our annual audit
letter I think that's enough that need
for now so on myself and I think you'll
be happy to take any questions that they
have Rob I assume that all the points
that have been raised are being
addressed properly and will be covered
fully yep yep so if I'll go into because
I was going to cut this in my from my
section so if we discuss some of the key
things that the younger raise
particularly around the asset valuation
so to be honest the the rocks would
finance team are clearly a little bit in
the middle of this because the the
valuation work is done by an external
value at work's headed Eve Wilkes had an
e VAR a national company and he were
obviously international and actually
this is quite a decent a national
problem this isn't just the problem in
Rochford there's been discussions of
quite seeking in that order to be fair
so we're in the same position and I
won't name but many many other roles are
in this exact same position so we're a
little bit we have to see how Ernst and
Young and the value is start to work out
what is the best process in the future
and then we would obviously try and
adhere to that as best we can but
actually we were only were a little bit
victims of the these position versus
actually I have possibly not to
influence it as such so we can monitor
closely and obviously we're not going to
have a huge amount of influence in this
case so we have to say by our value
assay and then we have to compare with
what Evo I say and then try and see if
we can form an opinion but I'll be
honest if we can't form an opinion in
here if they can't form an opinion
nationally they love watches it's not
gonna have much of a say either so
that's that's one thing and the same
with the pension valuation so I believe
that you know our pensions are completed
by an external actuary again we have to
take you know how to our work is
extremely complicated and something
we're never going to understand fully so
we have to take on value what we're
buying in and therefore that sort
valuation or over pension is very much
at a national level with Ernst and Young
and several of the actuarial valuations
companies therefore again we're a little
bit of a we have to sit in the middle
and just see what actually comes out so
those two are is not a lot we can do
about certainly the other areas
absolutely so the Housing Benefit
Journal that wasn't posted we have since
handy in an expert coming from Essex
County Council when they called
Francesca Price who is an expert
nationally recognized in the Housing
Benefit she is coming confirmed all the
process if we do not correct and
actually it was just a timing issue on
the journal nothing else so we know
we're in a good show that was just that
it will actually got missed versus
actually making some fundamental mistake
so and some of the other smaller areas
yeah I mean let's be honest there will
always be errors in these types of
things are extremely complex financial
accounting in local government and it
gets harder and harder the more things
like that Co you do group accounts and
start with some of the property stuff so
we will get harder we will make small
mistakes obviously we're here to try and
minimize those mistakes as much as we
can I'll be amazed if an auditor never
picks up something that's that's what
we're going for this isn't it so as I
say the best we can we do the best we
can with this but we certainly pick up
the point
and going on to that there was a you
know several points were raised in last
year's audit and I'm quite pleased to
say actually we've addressed every one
of those we've got clean bill of health
on those so we we do move forward we do
take notice of what the well be why our
external auditor say and we do take it
on board and we do try fix things so
it's just a continuing evolving process
unfortunately and so if I make sure my
going to mine does just come back to my
level set the value of the properties so
the council owns did you say they were
over valued no we're still happy that
there we've been a within a reasonable
range we just think there are towards
the top end of that range that that's
that's our professional judgment so it
doesn't mean they're overvalued but
we're just raising the point because you
know we do have this ongoing discussion
with Wilkes Headley and potentially is
there in some cases problems could be
overvalued not this year but potentially
they could in the future that could make
a bit of the difference to the final
thing is in Goodman yes it could do
anything we can do to address that well
now if we are to be fair what the
difference will be is Harrods shown on
the balance sheet so to show the assets
that we are near won't impact any of the
budget numbers he won't impact any
Americal Spence that's purely how
they're presented on to the bouncy so
whereas we've got valuation at the
moment a common fix demand of you know
50 60 million it may be I don't know if
that's overstated by say five percent it
would come down it would only be in
their balance sheet would that actually
shop
so actually there's not a lot of other
impact in terms of what we spent or our
services and things like that so in
terms of an actual impact on how the
council Ramsey is absolutely fairly
minimal but clearly we want to make sure
we report it incorrectly
okay thank you always be variable of me
absolutely I mean there's always an
element of opinion here that's that's
the point it's just how close we can
lastly line will tell you to get
together to make sure it works in total
so come in comes well quite thank you
super one
I think hopefully nobody is just about
the same things around that not so much
around 8's a revaluation but partly but
also around the the pension which are
shippin to about the pension liability
potential liability yeah I assume we're
talking around the fact that is within
the materiality level can you just
remind me what the materiality figure is
not wasting 75 million thousand pounds
you've set the the issue around the
revaluation of the assets is quite
common to rob a Red Bull fairly common
trying to use the words of use around
nationally is this because is this
through the council using the same
company that we use or is it other
companies doing it or is there any one
company who really does it the
revaluation message so we we have found
issues with the company the council uses
in other areas of the country I suspect
we've had to do more work in this area
this year because our regulator has they
across the door to auditors you're not
doing that work I suspect there may be
other firms who are we going to be
looking at more closely in the future
and we're going to be coming up with
some similar or well yes they were
similar issues but at the moment it is
this particular company that we are
encountering that the most significant
problems with okay thank you I'm done
the pension valuation is are a similar
issue there or is it just a one-off is
it the UM the concern basically arises
from how the the firm of Actuaries read
off some various drafts and and data to
pick out their discount rates and
inflation assumptions
from the memory as I understand they
basically use one point on the graph
whereas other firms are all using a
range or a blended rate which does make
the figures slightly and a few slightly
more accurate than just picking off the
one point that you're actually use so
ourselves our firms and the national
office are talking to them to see if
there is any potential improvement they
can make to their methodology for future
years but what could happen then if they
didn't change the methodology we could
find our patron arbiter to affect our
counts quite significantly perhaps not
materially in your your sense but quite
significant which that's that's positive
pension liability does tend to fluctuate
significantly every year because of the
changes in discount rates inflation
returns on government bonds for example
it's always moving like that so it's
only ever a problem if the pension
liability actually crystallizes there
any one point yes which is going to be
quite unlikely if you continue to take
longer-term view which which happens
every three years you have to try a new
evaluation your contribution rates then
adjusted the plan then is overtime even
come back the problem we have is
basically the balance sheet has to pick
a position our point in time it always
varies we just think they're a drive
along too misty look to two their
critical figures thank you I might just
add to that just just to avoid a any
fears and what we've also done over the
last few years is something we do is
called the training valuation and as
kevin has said which is basically we put
an amount of money aside and to cover
our liability or part of our liability
what we've done over the last few years
is actually put slightly too much chips
we have built up a reserves we have got
a little bit of cash there if this dust
does start to continue down the room we
think not that actually make the
liabilities worse we have got a buffer
before this really does start to hit us
so we are we have got a little bit in
there to buy did you get robbed in order
and we're not I was just going to sort
of do a couple of thing
people noticed very quickly was there's
there's quite an important section here
called the annual government statement
which I'm just particularly proud of how
I think I'm going to share that more so
I wrote it so last year as Kevin said
we've had a particularly issue with our
value for money so we were we have
qualified accounts for value at money
and what that was all around was we
didn't have a chief audit executive in
place at the time so there was so when
that Anson young come in there was there
was not a lot of insurance there in
terms of the internal processes now what
we've managed to do is you know we had
great Mortimer in from Essex for a year
so he came in said she for the executive
did a fantastic job with Jim and the
rest audit internal audit table and got
us up to a reasonable level then really
of the survey so Greg unfortunately left
us and we got my poor to him for battlin
inquiry is good and so mike has been
able to write this report that says we
have now got adequate assurance from his
point of view and that the internal
management structure you know controls
and processes are all fairly good which
is then helped continually be able to
give us an unqualified value for money
so for me that's a seismic shift in
where we were a year and that we just
obviously quite a big positive news for
us so that's my big seller tomorrow
thank you right we are being the
recommendation is for the Commission
resolves that the financial estate must
be approved and signed by the chairman
that the move the movement in the amount
reserves be noted agreement
moving on to item 8 which is proposal
committee resolves that the appointment
we know Peter village Ernst empty young
and as you've sold it to for eighteen
nineteen prepare to five years unless
the body ceases to exist all the body
ceases to fall within the class the
authorities for which the SKA is the
appointed person on this one so and
about a year ago couple years ago but
all local government was told they need
to go and repro cure their own external
audit services as of next year
previously this was all done for us from
the National Audit Office and then that
was found out something major firms less
than young which we read now and so we
were Oxford decided to become part of a
national framework to go and procure
this external audit because that we
could get a much better value for money
and actually a much greater range of
services so we joined something like 99%
of other local government into this
arrangement of the PSA a and what PSA I
did for us was going on procure an
external audit for us from not next year
but the year after and I'm very pleased
to say that for us the the auditors who
have been appointed we've had young
appointed again for another five years
which for us is a we think it's very
very good think you know we kept an
increase in team for now for a couple of
years they understand how we work we
understand how they work and the
processes that do work quite well
together so it's been quite you know
it's quite a good thing for us the other
side of it is we should see a slight
reduction around 18 percent in our fees
and because of this because it's been
procured nationally so we've been able
to get some sort of volume by outfit so
so this is just recommending that it be
noted that we've got under the young
through that we don't see any particular
problems with that while we've have you
to resolve this recommendation is
exactly
Thank You item 9 its proposal it
resolves that the updation delivering
internal no plan B no T for the
conclusion as a result of complete audit
engagement senior editors turn 3 noting
that the updated Satan Saudi reservation
and it's for you know T thank you
this is the progress report on the work
in so a little bit since the junior
committee so it's not and advances we
had hoped and both of our parts are more
businesses that the council one of which
was unexpected items relating to
resources are covered in Section four on
the covering of course much of the work
since the last committee has been
focused on engine at the Housing Benefit
Saturday orbit work a summary which is
on page nine point twelve the details
details summary of the work of the
compliance officers in revenues and
benefits is shown in Section three
starting on page nine point four this is
a counter fraud or error based work
around council tax business rates and to
a lesser extent housing benefits
appendix one on page nine point seven is
a summary of completed all we've worked
with appendix 2 on nine point eight
providing the detail appendix three on
9.13 summarizes work done in two areas
with the limited scope of testing rather
than reviewing the end-to-end process of
that particular service or function an
appendix for from page 914 gives the
current position on recommendations that
were outstanding in the last committee
and those made since we have any
comments
just what it was depend on me
it's just go sailing a game that we've
got some what have had some staffing
issues with in terminal D I think this
has come up over the last two years I
know anytime we think the sorted and
then he happens of game I'm just
concerned that there's a a problem there
which we're not recognizing this there's
a reason why people lately for there's a
reason why we have a heist maybe we've
got my stuff so that whatever is it
common throughout all councils at the
moment or is this a particular problem
to us from some wings and I think it's
just as concerned that we might be
slipping in the old did came to a
multiprocessor King
just okay thank you yeah to be honest
it's something we had recognized so we
we know we not just us but a lot of
their local government around London a
stock are struggling with auditors at
the moment because they want to be
attracted by London on the salaries ii
can you know what they can pay certainly
the private sector so there is quite a
few issues there around some of the
professions and all here's one of them
now what we have worked with we start to
work with my porter in Bazzle and he is
recognized this from it i'm working both
of them as well that he is trying to
build a pool or in effect zero contract
our auditors so we're he's trying to
attract people that potentially want to
do turn time working potentially low you
know not full-time maybe you know a few
hours a day few hours a week type thing
so highly qualified auditor still that
wouldn't potentially be attractive to
our London firm but actually may be
attractive to us and if we share it out
as long as the pool between ourselves
better than Cox point all the other
districts actually it's going to work in
terms of workload and
and balance so he's working on that
currently at the moment and the last
discussion I had with him was that he
was very confident some of the CBC's had
him were exceptional and working people
that he would never have expected be
able to hire themselves right away so we
have recognized this is a particular
issue it's not just in Rockford it is
you know like I say certainly in the
whole of Essex and if not all the
surrounding counties of London but our
plan is to try and attract this through
some sort of a resource pole we can try
it all down also do we know how many
hours behind we are on the planet
I haven't mentioned well that went out
at the moment this is a t-shirt they're
not time of year with holidays certainly
we are looking to recruit a full-time
computer and we can then backfill using
my call of workers so we certainly still
be able to make only the key audience
excited enough to do there maybe once
maybe some slippage probably not not in
the position to actually got the phone
there yet just chairman if I if I may in
actual practice one of the those two
part-time auditors one was on a fixed
term contract the other did leave it
wasn't necessarily expected but it has
provided an opportunity so in terms of
in-house appointment we're looking at a
full-time five-day but other than the
four days that we've had up till now and
that would be a career graded post you
know proved quite attractive to to
someone to work with Jim for full time
and that's additional to what Rob was
mentioning which is the pool of staff
which have actually been interviewed and
is part of auditors thinking across the
councils to address the more general
issue health chairman
if I make this gesture which we
requested within the audit progress
report for their next meeting we have a
more detailed update on on that and what
the staffing situation untell we are
doing on ours absolutely where we are
pleased and he was worried we move quite
a position before absolutely sorry sorry
question about that so the trading arm
or reading it seemed very into the world
and with the council where the cancer
was looking over make sure it's doing
the job properly I know I'm a little bit
it's similar because it might some
looking in it might seem a little bit
too involved with a counselor at the
moment no again no weed down oddity
works being done and getting money back
from the company which is fine but
checking to make sure they've got all
the my insurance is in place anything
else are overlooking at the council was
you go to another company who's coming
to do a tender you know I haven't got
that sort of oversight it might come out
a little bit unfair same as a future
the company acts independently yeah I
know no but obviously the the scope of
this or group is making sure things were
set up correctly and it wasn't a review
of the day to day operations giving the
family secular did we get it right
are we doing the right recording I'm not
in position to make another judgment
stage yeah I think five depart agree
with you if it was an ongoing saga
nation was gonna be me who in their
process and stuff but this is very much
to give yourselves as members and our
owners officers that actually we have
got this rather we have set it up in the
right way so I do appreciate that but I
think this is quite a unique situation
which is once we've know we've got it up
and set up correctly it's now down to
the directors to balance things properly
the comfies we can stand back and just
hopefully worry about the digital
content on the non-dualistic
rights you've got a recovery there of
another 90 unregistered businesses but I
figure there 153 thousands but I'm
pretty sure that the vast majority of
those are going to be getting gratefully
153,000 council kicking in the door do
we get subsidized okay we'd have to kind
of a look at that value because it could
we could be could be anything to be
honest it could be that could be all
getting released nothing could given the
actual I mean the actual figure that
we're down in 53 that would be the
amount you to be expected to whether
it's or rather write relief or not are
you expecting that to come to the
coffers not necessarily no so that would
be done as far as I understand that
would be the full business rates that
they would pay there's lots of things
they calculate how much goes off to
central government how much goes off to
Essex County Council fire and then how
much comes to us eventually and it all
depends on for businesses they are on
what rate
what place they won't release that I
just couldn't take to be honest so we
certainly wouldn't be getting that 453
on the arkansaw yeah I thought I think
you misunderstood sorry website the
amount of races collected okay right the
umbrella figure yeah it sounds good when
you combine it with another 300 or so
expected in the coming year to be
identified it could be anything upcoming
quite a significant figure actually all
the brights collection but my question
was more on a case of does rate relief
then actually bring that figure down
generally I would not on the overall
figure or do we get does the rate relief
get compensation
anyway relief we give gets common sense
or central government yes of course I
think you sorry yes thank you any other
questions what their recommendation is
that we resolve those three points is
everybody happy to
amendments on the annual report this is
asking us to recommend and has proposed
that the committee resolves that the
amendment to the annual report in 92
thank you
this report we remain members aware of a
change in wording of the internal and in
opinion report that was presented to
this committee in June this changes
carried out at the request of the
external auditor in order that the
opinion given will match the wording of
the annual government statement which is
also be presented at that meeting any
questions everybody happy to
yeah yeah it's proposed if it resolves
at the contents of the footprint
respirator 1702 so there's a section 1.1
officer which reverses things but
through you
the council's corporate risk register
consideration
thank you judge let's do and so what you
have in front of you is that our update
on the corporate risk register and a
couple of updates think I may have
talked about these before but I'll
refresh everybody so certainly 3a and 3b
now if you go to page eleven point five
you notice that we've now broken now
previously this was a single risk around
environmental health and it was quite
confusing about what I actually meant so
we have a 3a which is around food or
environmental incidents or talk about
food safety standards things like that
and as fast as a medium at the moment
currently a few in last year the year
before there was a particular issue here
but there's been a focus on it with
Louise's team to get this down and then
within three feet there is then the
breakout of that which is around health
and safety so this is a health and
safety across the entire council so
potentially for staff and for members
and also then for the public as well now
he's still considered to be high which
is which is fine there is a an action
plan in place there's been quite a lot
of training that has gone on so far and
will continue into next year we have now
got an appointment of Rob French as our
as a Health and Safety Officer explosion
call him and he's you know daily looking
into this at what we need to do things
like fire certificates Legionella risks
especially serious things like that so
he's really going really going into it
we've got hopefully proposed a
reasonable amount of money don't need to
capital next year to start to refresh
some of the issues which we talked about
in June courses we get through the
budget so it's something that we do
recognize it's got a high risk and
hopefully some of the mitigations around
it are quite expensive but we
the next two that are reasonably higher
and these will always be higher I don't
think I'd ever see these come down
certainly not in my life so anyway which
is around the failure to produce an a
balanced budget each year as long as we
are still being squeezed in terms of
austerity and lack of funding this would
always be an issue and it's an issue we
just need to keep high on the gentleman
so you know we do our best every year
don't we to try and work out ways to you
know cut a cloth accordingly with the
funding requirements potentially look at
new funding streams things like that but
this would always be a risk and it
should provide that we sell out there as
hypotheses it's going to continue into
the long term to the long run
unfortunately link to that is is the
inability to recruit and retain staff
now we have seen a particular issue
around or we are seeing an issue
something again in the whole of the East
of England around salaries so I'm wrong
local government salaries are starting
to fall behind or behind a private
sector and are started behind other
local authorities London boroughs and
some of the other counties like Surrey
and Kent and so what that is means is we
do potentially have a very high risk of
losing some of that top talent some of
our staff because we cannot afford to
pay them the salaries that they
potentially deserve all that essentially
can get elsewhere so there's lots of
work going on at the moment with nickey
or more in HR to consider as part of the
people and what can we do around this
how can we retain our talent it's often
not just about salaries because there's
a whole you know whole Studies on this
that said if you pay someone more are
they really going to stay it's all
around working conditions it's about
better environment it's about feeling
empowered and all that sort of all that
sort of good stuff so there's lots of
work here still to be done but
unfortunately is going to be a high risk
and again I can't see this going down in
in the near term until we can start to
address some of our financial issues
then final one I want to bring your
attention to is item four is risk 14
which is the fact the potential failure
of roads I t's ICT estate now what this
isn't this isn't the ICT project this is
the IT in total towards the IT project
he's part of this and it's got
which register that is reported quite
regularly through the program board well
what this is saying is what is the
entire program looking at the entire
Mightiest they've looking like we have a
medium risk against it now I'm very
pleased to say that the IT migration
went very well over the weekend and so
therefore that we're hoping this risk
will certainly people continue at medium
I think that's quite fair but some of
the risks in terms of the ICT should now
be mitigated considerably by our move to
the to the cloud from the lift and shift
and eventually into the cloud as such so
I'm quite pleased that we've been able
to report that now this wasn't a couple
of weeks ago and I may have actually
thought it hi before we actually did the
migrations oh did you speak I know your
comments on the ICT project and it's
good to hear the state exact but one of
the things that concerns me is that in
way hopping back to report seven maybe I
should have all the update is that no
work has been done or otherwise on the
ICT project considering the situation
that we were in on previous contract do
you think that that's right that we
shouldn't have anything it's a report to
hear it was when the IT project is that
yeah
I mean to be fair you I suppose you
could about us I don't know if this is
the right forum to have asked for it
whether it needed to come from a review
committee or investment board potential
but there was a question of whether you
whether members could have asked for
more of an update potentially and they
Ricci is reported through the block say
from the program board which goes to
leader and deputy leader and it's now
part of the the monthly performance pack
we should be coming out on Friday which
will give an update as well so the
question is whether all the committee's
the right place where I
don't feel it is I'll be honest with you
potentially but maybe something for a
review committee something okay so is
there anything currently in place for
any member participation in the progress
of the Odyssey - yes so so there is
through the leader and deputy meetings
that go fire the program management
office and then equally if review
committee decides to ask in the ICT
program that's absolutely they can do
that so thank you thank you just sir
what an equation apparently the RC team
operation product is being reported back
to this committee in April of 2018
although with regard to the ICT as a
whole this is around this is about
monitoring our our ability to monitor
contracting as Catherine's alluding to
in the past week we have certainly been
lacking in our ability to monitor
contracts and think around this we just
want assurances that we are in a
position to the money to contracts
because ICT is one of the big ones
obviously the other ones were measure
which I think are being looked as well
through this year because outside in the
imported kind of beginning 13 term next
time I'll just mention those and I think
it's assurances around the monitoring of
the variability to my native contracts
being provided by an external provider
which might have much more expertise
than we do and whether we can be fooled
by thermal blocks and whether we're
adequately or I have the knowledge
in-house to monitor them as well I think
there buddy sees that one of the big
problems we've come across in the past
but not least is a concern around IC t
at the moment that up a lack of
monitoring previously or lack of
understanding previously map given us
worries or concerns around the migration
and that's what so they I've got another
Christian Endeavor that's that that I
think that Oh
are we happy week or able to point to
the ICT on other contractors week I mean
work from our point of view we said we
believe you are as officers but I think
if you feel that it's something you
would like to look to happen if somebody
probably something to discuss with Jim
and Mike Porter around the body plan
next year say could you add that you
know as a potential item to look at
contract management at the RIT part of
the OIT suite going forward yes is this
right yes a contract management is done
depending on where we do it so we could
do it on you could do as a whole
obviously it's quite a big face or you
could do it on specific contracts it's
as the only committee since Holly up to
you how you decide to do that I'm pretty
sure it was on the program given to you
which I do not have in front of me
unfortunately fine if I were take
ourselves I thought that by the Chairman
to to Jim it that so far no I don't want
one officer and the other question was
around or my question is clearly is
around the four point one pane as item
three things which may be pulled out
separately which doesn't pose or not for
and which is a risk which is already
being sex I've undo their the concerns
around that yes we got something in
there they were working on a mobile
integrated as soon as it can be but the
indication from four point one
suggesters
only minor administrative changes were
made to three-bean and then he's not
going to be able to gain the next season
coming year or the next advance is that
correct is that how it should tell which
should we be wondering a bit more
closely I mean from seven so from a from
an officer point of view that we had
leadership team this morning this was
agenda item number two so it's been
taking very seriously seriously
certainly own officer level and we are
monitoring this stuff constantly and it
eats a bit more than just by the way
look
come back there's quite a few actually
to come out of that I suppose the
question becomes is there is it in the
audit plan currently for this year I
don't have a family so I can't look if
they wished wants to be a change to that
that you'd rather look at this and
something else I suppose that change
could happen but it's gonna have to be
decided what does all of the audio play
if knowing did then we add it into the
post a pool or the computer absolutely
so the environmental health and health
and safety are all this year's audit
plan the health and safety to follow up
to complete what we started last year
ago working progress report this time
there will be an opinion given so he's
under slightly misleading you suggesting
someone if you don't add any I'm happy
that he's been looked as you say but on
how I see a summary rc4 access the Iraq
yeah might be slightly was bleeding yeah
we can amend that report Cherokee thank
you thank you okay I'll stop him yeah I
noticed that in the risk assessment item
14 in fact covers mention of ICT and
some of the previous problems we had
with my storage shouldn't occur in the
future because using the azure cloud the
updates are all there so we've got that
this is good
I noticed that in looking at the
contract though there's an ozone there's
different rates for low and high
interruption of business per server
there's 80 servers you know so that kind
of thing I know it doesn't down the
detail
I may have to just get up I don't mind I
can't remember it Oh ICT project on
Atlantis and colleagues is still in PNC
we just got our thing is obviously they
would expect some sort of report once
it's all about which is good
sorry I didn't mean to cut your I saw
you don't need to get as much trouble so
here they're looking at it on the ICT so
can it look another thing in the future
there is one issue I want some Identity
Management the changes in data
protection than the filings are horrific
if anything leaks out is a risk so
perhaps we might in the next year
include something about that although is
a change of the law coming in yes
subject would be another chair I agree
we are currently looking at that year
again public leadership team part
another three was the changes to data
protection which we are considering we
could need to look at how we resource
that internally how we look at all our
processes it's it's gonna be making the
impact and yeah quite a few big fines
that could become in our life well if we
were to do something wrong so yeah
something we are physically yeah thanks
are there any other questions or enemies
so the resolution is that we agreed
let it be noted that you go to the
amendment is that great mr. John and I
understand that your replacement is with
us tonight
yes introduced tiny Lucas please
you thank you very much
okay thank you the make you guys